you
all right we have liftoff and I'm not
competing in this tournament instead I'm
going to check out the games that are
being played such as this guy he has
beaten me
I believe D gallon is playing as team
black a wonderful Bishop on e5 also
white is up upon two very good reasons
to prefer team white here trying to get
into this efore push Smyth insists on
getting the darks for Bishop it's just
not happening Bishop has too many
squares along this diagonal in-betweener
okay so we still have material plus a
bad bishop poor development on the black
side a weak pawn h7 is hit maybe this
was better to have a flight square to
defend against the threat and still have
a flight square which would be on a dark
square rook here material material wise
okay still down timewise is about even
and how do you get this bishop out of
here okay now would repair the structure
a little bit to exchange Queens so
that's why we're having that avoided and
this guy actually 2320 trade at the at
the cost of pawn structure so now that
not a bad idea get the King to f6 and
have this pawn push to open up this
diagonal for the bishop I don't know if
I would have as white put upon fixed on
a light square he's a potential target
bishop here you have to be reacting so
we are having this another pawn that's a
potential target so what do you do about
this actually now I'm preferring black
black is the side is better in fact this
pond is blockaded to pond advantage now
this pond is falling this is a one King
and pond endgame another pond on a light
Square Wow
did the tables turn with that one black
down two seconds but has three pounds I
will be taking black any day plenty of
time resignation interesting start
let's try this one nap three this guy I
can say for sure has never fallen for an
h2 mate I've tried time and time again
against nap three
to get made on h2 but it just never
happens so if you're looking for a good
setup with how to defend against those
little tricks this guy knows a way to do
it he's never fallen for it and
apparently there is no action here yes
there is yes there is 2144 vs. 1953 fast
development a dutch defense striking at
the center c4 Knight c3 okay Fein keto
this bishop very strong I would be
recapturing at the knight as well cuz
you want to keep this diagonal clear
this Knight is looking to regroup that's
why we're again having piece captures on
d4 this bishop does not want to be
obstructed d5 now becomes a whole night
b1 to c3 might not be a bad idea I don't
know how well-placed he would be on f3
the bishop is observing this square but
now it runs into potential efore
advances and sure enough we are having
that the elimination of the LightScribe
bishops is a good thing you probably
better play here right now otherwise
black gets to free up this deep on our
exchange an unhealthy deep on for a
perfectly healthy C pond that was Czech
Bishop takes here is available
exploiting the pin on the rook but maybe
capturing here first is best because
this could be an annoying thorn f3 okay
it's still this pin you have to take
with the king otherwise you wouldn't
have that threat you and have that pin
anymore the bishop if you're dropping
drops back there's g5 g 5 is available
subjects the king g5 was there but it
was missed
as punished hit three times maybe look
for a c5 or an e5 push less than 10
seconds for black down on time and
position and now we're just up a rook up
a clean rook this is game over
is it not less than five seconds we're
gonna have resignation resignation next
game jump in that one this one is
different two different players bloomin
versus batter bombs Knight takes Queen
width check that's game over rook takes
its main two
okay how do you what's the cleanest
approach probably just take the brook
and take the bishop rook takes Bishop
Knight takes Bishop take the bishop okay
get the Queen on this diagonal no I
actually don't do that rook here get the
rooks off when you have that particular
imbalance which it's not even about an
imbalance here when it's the imbalance
Queen versus rooks you want to trade off
one of the rooks messes up with White's
coordination that's a that's a fourth
they had they had Bishop takes net I
guess they they missed that in fact they
were maybe just down more material next
game man you will 1795 versus 21 18 I've
played this guy before Oh what did this
come out of a Scandinavian big trouble
where's the Queen F to go a place where
she can't develop and now this is a
nasty pin probably tried to a castle on
opposite sides essentially since you
don't want to cancel Queen side and you
can't Castle queenside c3 has hit this
bishop has hit Bishop takes Knight Queen
takes Bishop remove the defender Bishop
takes Knight if Bishop takes Knight
Bishop takes Bishop no we're not having
that the bishop is gone just like that
rook be one night here don't do not here
actually it's tempting
it was definitely tempting pawn push
here Bishop takes Knight you can't
defend like that so how do you defend
night here Knight here with b6 that's a
good structure that'll secure the whole
Kings side although it's hit three times
now oh the Kings gay after ugh 25 to 23
24 the King is running for his life
still running for his life there's gonna
have to be a block on D 7th King here
Queen takes pawn the knight would after
night or Brooke would have to block
another check we're gonna be having that
no or not the rook is there to block
this Knight is a very good defender
against Queen checks when she's checking
the King that's when she's very close to
the King when she checks or tries to
check rook takes rook is the threat this
rook is not doing anything and we might
be having something against this king
over here white is just down on time and
position black wins
what is another one here how about this
one deals gambit team black and looking
pretty good here being up material okay
I thought for a second take the Queens
the rook takes and then Bishop takes
Knight but the Brooke would be guarding
here material is even this punished past
this Bishop is super annoying flight
square needed for black less than 15
seconds to do it
the pawn is marching I'll watch out for
back rank mates both sides are sensitive
to back rank mates 15 no 16 seconds made
on g2 it's defended again g5 highly
committal but maybe it's good Oh going
back and forth
Queen trade got to play fast eight point
two seconds for black rook and pawn
endgame rook and there's still
possibilities for me still possibilities
for me on each one or order the H file
the H file that's me
it's backdoor I was a backdoor threat oh
nice
Oh King up and rook over you saw that
one coming okay again kills gamma is
coming off of a stunner right there an
unexpected maid Knight g4 is available
they got to do h3 before f4 space
advantage for black this pawn looks like
he's just gonna be picked up 92 to f3 or
g2 here take yeah Bishop g2 to here
there's no saving him pawn push is
available this pawn is pinned Castle
down opposite sides push pawns exploit
this pin put another piece on it night e
2 to here don't take my e 2 to f4 get
your last piece working or that win a
piece it's more direct g5 that was the
last safe square the bishop had on e7 41
234 now I guess you could take
because queen takes is there or maybe
bishop here Queen takes pawn though okay
finally the last pieces in their wrote
here is not a good idea
the Queen would take twice and then the
Queen would have to block okay Knight
here hitting the Queen push this pawn a
couple times very good h5 h6 weakens the
dark squares and this King is going to
be in some serious hot water very nice
so take here open up this diagonal get
rid of this pond Queen here check and
then made on g7 okay it's the bishop
who's trying to get to that square the
queen would be even better try to
envision that Queen on that g7 square
black is trying to hold on for dear life
but I don't see it happening bishop
could take here Bishop takes Bishop less
than 10 seconds that was a free bishop
wasn't it I think it was Queen here this
is what you would really like Queen g7
less than five okay getting out of the
way it's a clearance Queen g7 nope okay
that was just uh let's do that no matter
what
Aipom didn't have any time white white
won that one these are all the top games
this is the leader right here batter
bombs sixteen seconds to 24 seconds
Knights still on the board piece is gone
oh gee - I know the feeling yeah I know
the feeling of G - watch out get them if
the rook is here and there's a knight on
f3
you could weave a mane there goes a rook
or a pond ah you missed that 3.1 seconds
for white not happening serious time
advantage serious rook f2 to here do
something sneaky are you gonna lose on
time take the rook quick black one no
time I just ready to say back to
tournament let's take a look at this
game nap here I accidentally clicked on
this this is not one of the top games
down to minor pieces is why the rook up
and over it's a possibility you know no
possibility no hope
gonna have me soon very soon queen trade
I missed that Queen takes Queen this
game's over I'm done looking at that one
that was over another top game what's
the leaderboard actually 50 41 39 okay
let's take a look at this guy
team black let's look at it from the
blacks perspective let's see a black
stone time is even ooh what an
interesting in Game three six materials
even who would you prefer definitely
white doubled pawns you don't want to
keep your pawns on dark squares this
King could sneak in on these light
squares King here King there put
pressure on this pawn or this one get
this bishop active bishop here to here
ship here to here is very good not now
there's not a better position for the
King I don't believe King needs to stay
here now this pawn might have this uh
deflected King here King here this pawn
push might have been available and now
white is up material Bishop takes here
is available there goes the HP on now
the a pond is rumbling to passed pawns
good King position now even better King
position and you even worse here for
black so these pawns are gonna roll
White has 15 seconds to what a good time
edge 13 seconds to less than three team
white going to score a touchdown very
soon white wins forfeit on time let's
check another one out deals gambit again
he's up there 42 points 42 points and
this seems like he came about from so
it's a benoni so type of bony structure
and this is this is a problem now even
if black didn't have this beep on it's
still very difficult this pond will be
killed any second pawn push there's no
contesting this a file with blacks
control a one now so this night will
look to regroup
whereas his ideal square this isn't this
isn't a bad one are we gonna have some
action on the h-file now he did
something like this earlier you got to
watch over this pun okay rook here
there's maybe ideas now okay that's the
lateral defense is best interesting
interesting interesting okay get on the
F F pawn black is completely committed
to this Queen side this section of the
board alright now what am I talking
about the Queen is here to defend
against f7 she has to drop back to g7
this is winning material and rule these
pawns are very deep so this this is a
pass beep on maybe push right away or
just go right after this connected
passed pawns two sets of connected
passed pawns oh man
you have to get the King involved I
think this was not a good idea this King
is there to defend very nice move though
King here to defend King d8 less than
four three two one no time they weren't
moving to check the server 1.9 Wow
they were they use a ton of time rook
here would have been best uh white wins
Wow let's check out another game from
mr. mr. deals gambit there that was a
that was it that was a sharp game there
let's see another one right round the
gates how's this oh this guy playing
here what is going on so some type of a
scotch opening it seems take that night
no you don't you want to open up that
e-file so quickly rook here would deter
black from taking this night because now
we could have rook check rook check and
then Queen here and there wouldn't be a
way to get out of the pin highly
committal move moving that Jeep on twice
this pawn is now hit Oh giving up a pawn
just to rip open the black King side
position but white doesn't have a lot of
development here why black is the better
developed side tonight is not far off
from obtaining a good post on
or d5 eliminate the dark square bishop
would be nice and then get the bishop on
this diagonal black is not allowing that
and by dropping back Queen h4 is
available now you hear pawn push again
we're gonna see another pond land on f6
ouch
oh man Knight takes Knight pawn takes
Bishop with check oh man this is gonna
go downhill there's not a better post
for that Queen nice and central on the
light Square covering any potential
checks here up a piece might even be
some rook checks there's an odd way to
get the Queen on this diagonal just yet
but this SH up here to here looks simple
and good okay Queen trade this is me
Queen takes Queen Bishop here game over
lights out oh those dark squares that
pawn sack on f6 just to disrupt the
heart of that structure that g7 pond is
brutal eighty-seven to forty this is the
leader I hear playing as white who is
now down on time seven point six to
twelve has an advantage I prefer white
absorb lack objectively here a nice
Bishop post two connected passed pawns
securing G seven point three seconds
it's not happening actually there would
be a one rook at that point black wins
that one and now I think we're gonna
have a shift here with the leaderboard
85-82
alright those two guys gonna be paired
up let's see 85-82 how's this guy doing
85-82
white this is the guy who's in second
place who's playing as white okay
preserving the bishop ideally since
black does not have a dark square bishop
and white does you want to get that
Bishop on this dark diagonal so c4 is
good to not only kick the knight but get
bishop c3 and pig on the seventh I still
like this move watching over these light
squares not a bad idea at all
c4 also allows the bishop takes pawn one
day a four c4 come to mind you already
as well you have a flight square I'm not
quite sure what the Queen was doing
and she has to play here every other
square is covered
no actually Queen takes pawn here was
available okay maybe White's gonna try
this again pawn push and that is finally
kicked and black I think should be
trying to break down this structure so
opposite color Bishop ending how exactly
do assess this you don't want a week in
your light squares white is doing well
to have pawns on light squares works
well with this bishop and now is
targeting these weaklings on c5 and a
for whites persistent with pigs on the
seventh looking to maybe get some push
in if the bishop moves it's going to be
bad news very nice to break down this
dark square diagonal with g5 + f4 it's
gonna make that bishop Rumble and we
just simply have no time for black-white
wins that one is maybe first or second
at this point 102 to 89 102 to 89 where
is that guy right somewhere 89 89 this
guy's up there let's look at it from his
perspective team black is one of the one
of the leaders 89 points up a full-piece
and down just a little bit of time but
is getting something back and not so
fast though oh okay wait a second what
am I talking about just a pawn advantage
now for black this pawn is covered this
night is gonna be trapped bishop here
bishop here bishop here Oh
bishop here would trap the night you
still have it Bishop here
Bishop right here right and then Bishop
here to c4 and the knight would be dead
I have to be careful about the Knights
on those edges a bishop placed three
squares away from it just running from
the edge of the board cuts off all
squares that it could be going to and
this is a one King and pawn endgame now
four
team black team black 17 seconds new
queen on the scene and this is going to
be game over black wins we have
resignation leaderboard 109 102 from
Nepal versus le okay let's check out le
here playing against nap who's up there
as well I think this is the leader right
here with one or two blacks perspective
this is the leader and it looks like
it's gonna be made very soon very very
soon discovered tricks here this bishop
does nothing nor does this one until one
of these two pawns move and it's only
really ever one of these two bishops
that could ever do something you push
here he's kind of dead you push here
he's not doing much one or the other but
not both bishop here check and Bishop
takes pawn with check you can keep going
back and forth it's really the queen
that wants to get to this square and
that's what black is setting up but now
white is getting the rook active less
than seven seconds for black less than
seven seconds this is the this is the
leader here let's check your queen here
less than three seconds do I have the
times correct white wins the leader just
forfeited on time back to the
leaderboard 109 to 100 okay alright
let's check out this guy this is the
leader team white who better be very
careful this pawn is actually acting as
a good defensive piece for white you
capture here and you're more vulnerable
on the dark squares this Knight is hit
this Queen is a monster Wow
defends the knight just keep this Bishop
sitting what's that that's allowing
Queen here or me Queen takes pawn queen
here whoa Queen takes pawn what's
happening what is white what is black
thinking about the Queen is hit Queen
takes pawn you don't have to defend the
bishop you got made on a 100 is missed
oh there goes the
just like that the tables turn white is
up now material and time no hope
Oh an interesting opportunity there to
get down to that a1 square the lead the
leader is still up there won that game
129 to 110 less than nine minutes remain
all right check this guy out again is he
gonna slip up if he doesn't slip up it's
gonna be game over tournament over very
fast development serious issue on this
diagonal the Queen gets out of it right
away the knight is ready you look for
discovery white was looking to get rid
of the knight and then take on aged 700
this is gonna make black think the
bishops there to defend White's trying
to remove the defenders but is running
out of fuel
Black has quite plenty of defenders
there's no way to get another piece in
you could take here twice if you really
wanted to
I'm necessary I guess throw the knight
in here or here get this F pawn rolling
the Queen is hit Black has enough
defenders but this pawn is gonna run
down and OH
made on h2 No g2 it's defended with f4
the queen is there laterally here comes
the ape on the night is gonna be kicked
and it could come down here this could
be a problem this is covered Knight here
not an issue h6 okay oh the quote you're
trying to deflect the Queen from defense
here take that Queen out of there
release the pressure against g2 somehow
okay now the rook is there to defend
which frees up the Queen we're about
even on time 28 each pawn push this is
very scary now for black swinging this
Knight over here to defend his back fire
because white is advancing the pawns
with tempo and this is losing material
uh-oh oh you could have just taken here
there's no rook check bishop takes here
first Oh missed opportunity
there's check down down on time black is
down on time just a little bit can't get
it's tough to get out of the pin rook
here so a bishop here is available so
the rook you finally move this rook is
here this rook is defended rook takes
rook opposite color Bishop ending go
fast ten seconds remaining g2 oh there
goes a rook don't blink
don't blink there goes a bishop run with
this pond oh this is gonna be game over
if White knows how to play fast this is
going to be game over push push push
that's me that's me it's gonna be mate
oh the leaders slipped up you drop back
which means what how have things changed
if at all 127 126 let's check out
another one 127 126 let's see how this
guy's done one 126 this guy is in second
place and he's needing to keep winning
here I would really like this structure
if black was still uncashed and there
could be some play on the h-file this
Knight would love to be on d3 looking at
that furthest advanced pawn and the
support points it has d3 as a whole is
there really a great way to get him
there I guess not sure what night here's
doing I like the idea of Knight f5 d6 to
c4 that seems the most reasonable square
to get to this is covered he's going
really in a direction that's making him
making him a Hopf sides the knight is to
come back there's not a better Square
and now we're losing material ouch
black is slipping up here we're having
the leaders and towards the end here
slipping up but playing against a tough
player here 2020 209 mark Gibson in a
time edge to up a piece and up 10
seconds this looks very very promising
for team white I think black again was
going astray with those Knight moves
white seeking exchanges also looking to
just go after this pawn who cares about
this guy go right after him okay
moving the knight rook takes pawn bishop
check King has to play here the rook is
gone this is gonna be another W another
W for somebody who's not as a leader
there how have things changed their
meter slipped up which means is anybody
else available 148 Dill's gamba I don't
know
they're sneaking up he is apparently
rebounded from that nasty mate that
happened with the bishop going to this
square I forget what color he was but
there was that Bishop check and then me
his King was in the corner looking for
mate on g7 that is defended immediately
light square issues for Team white let's
look from blacks perspective this is the
leader 148 Dill's gambit 25 seconds to
33 seconds
what's this King gonna do if the bishop
plays here the bishop plays here that's
basically saying King you can't go
anywhere neither Direction is good okay
can you break down this Dino the Queen
is there up a peace drop this Bishop
back rook takes pawn here even on time
pawn push oh they're in pre-move mode
this pawns falling it twice rook check
you could sneak this King all the way up
here and grab f2 there's no activity for
the rook and that would have been a
nasty check right here pawn push very
nice I actually have to give up the pond
get the King working oh this is me
boom-boom that's me
that would have been made on each one
yeah that Bishop was covering the h1
square plenty of time to do it though 12
seconds 148 this is gonna turn into 168
black wins and with that still maintains
the lead 168 137 let's watch the leader
if he does not slip up he's going to win
this is his last game or second to last
game and he has a tough opponent
21:28 Dill's gambit in the lead 168 if
he wins here I think he has the
tournament Bishop checked this is coming
out of the what I missed it okay now a
Scandinavian defense so this could be a
knowing pawn push is not a threat
because there's this pin black sees that
immediately still not a threat until
there's castle that's not a threat but
castling might allow for Bishop takes
pawn on h3 Castle kingside Castle
queenside opposite sides castling the
Queen is hit bishop here I thought Queen
here Castle and then something like g4
this rook is opposite the Queen so
Knight c5 might be available g4 Knight
takes pawn is there
there was still that pen there's still
that pen for as long as the Queen was on
the h-file c4 is hit defend like this
bishop here dark square weaknesses
castle get castled pawn takes 34 seconds
to 30 34 34 the knight is hit the knight
is defended pawn push pawn push here
isn't needed oh no no no I made this a
mate threat this is a mate threat these
squares are covered by the bishop that's
very difficult to stop huh you can't
stop it oh yeah you could you could do
that move the King has a square finally
he could breathe King here if Knight
takes Knight takes on a 7 I wasn't
seeing that defense the just the rook
lifts of the King add another square you
couldn't move you couldn't do anything
about the night getting to a 7 so you
had to make some air for the King 20
seconds to 17 seconds time edge and how
do you even keep track of this game it's
free minor pieces each this pawn is
going to file the bishop is hit look
takes h3 the king is in check take on h3
tricky Knights who knows how many Forks
at the midst take this night night in
pawn the game less than 10 seconds 14
black it looks pretty good here there's
a knight check which pawns gonna fall
there's check here King here time is
catching up black is flying black has
kicked it into a new gear less than 5
seconds for white this pond is gonna
fall tricky checks for less than 5 less
than 5 to 8 Oh go fast listening for run
King game aborted oh that was a terrible
fitness I guess the tournament finished
uh-oh it didn't even allow him to get
that last win oh he was so close to
getting that win maybe ah I know how
that feels what the tight one though
from Nepal the winner 177 nap 3 168
deals gambit 168 missing out on those
tiebreaks
top three finishers those guys were
going back and forth
good tournament good games all all right
you